well you can tell
everybody yeah you can tell
everybody go ahead and tell
everybody I'm the man I'm the man I'm
the man yes I am yes I am yes I am I'm
the man I'm the man I'm the man I
believe every lie that I ever told paid
where every heart that I ever stole I
played my cards and I didn't fold well
it ain't that hard when you got so this
is my world somewhere I heard that life
is a test I've been through the words
but I still get my best God made my Mo
different from the rest then he broke
that more so I know I'm
bless stand up now and face the Sun
Won't hide my tail or turn and run it's
time to do what must be done and now the
champion Alex
[Applause]
youbody
I'm
everybody go ahead and tell
everybody I'm the man I'm the man I'm
the man yes I am yes I am yes I am I'm
the man I'm the man I'm the
[Music]
man